s
et les mieux entraînés du monde.
Ils sont Roumains, Améininins
et Britanniques. Ce matin, ils
naviguent dans les eaux troubles
et brume d d de la mer Noire, au
large de Constanta, en Roumanie.
l'Ukraine n'est qu'à 150 km.
Leur missn,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,nr
des insurgés qui ont perturbé
le commamamamaritime en Europe.
évidemment, mais le simuler
comme ils le font n'a
été aussi important pour tester
la coordination des alliés
de l'OTAN. C'est une valse
de précision entre des soldats
où l'erreur n'est pas permise,
surtout pas avec les tensions
qui hantent la région.
L'hélicoptère arrive
justement d'un de ces exercices
en mer Noire. C'est le genre
de routine pour les forces
de l'OTAavavavavavec le risque
d'un conflit direct avec
la Russie qui augmente,
les bases, comme celle-ci
à Constanta, en R
ont été mises en état d'alerte.
aqaqaqaqaque jour, au moins
trois avions de combat comme
ses Typhoon décollent de la base
à une situation anormale.
Avant que la guerre commence,
ça n'arrivait qu'une fois
par se
i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.i.
Pas plus grande que deux
terrains de foot
est devenue un des territoires
les plus disputés dans la guerre
entre la Rus
Constamment prise pour cible
par les tirs de l'armée russe,
l'OTAN la surveille. Elle n'est
qu'à 45 km des eaux roumaines.
eseseseseseses de débordement
sont réels.
Et pas juste en Roumanie.t t tr
la plupart des bases militaires.
Les Canadiens débarqueront
p p p p p p p pour s'entraîner
à leur tour alors que l'OTAN
est confrontée à l'unananananan.
Ici, Tamara Alteresco,
Constanta, Roumanie